[Music]
the rock versus Tyrese Dwayne Johnson
opened up about the fast and furious
dude last night on live TV
have you and Tyrese talked since he
called you on Instagram
after you agreed to do your own fast and
furious spin-off the answer's no no we
haven't we haven't talked at all and you
know that whole thing with Tyrese was it
was pretty disappointing because I've
been friends with Tyrese for a very long
time to me there's no need to have a
conversation he had voiced his opinion a
lot on social media and he apparently he
was going through some stuff too in his
personal life what more do you want from
me
Tyrese broke down in November during his
contentious custody battle over his
ten-year-old daughter and he defended
fast co-star Vin Diesel when the rock
called him out apparently for a lack of
professionalism this brother right here
no one will ever know what I know about
how hard Ben works behind the scenes I
will call you guys later a source tells
et today don't expect to see the rock
working with Tyrese or VIN anytime soon
but another source tells us it's
possible down the road if a reunion
might feel like a big event
life's too short and work is too
important excuse my language so I
refused to do that
meanwhile the rock did just revealed to
et who's joining the franchise just fine
mr. Silva these would be the bad guys
the bad guy and the rock social media
muscle is making news today Forbes is
reporting that starting with his latest
film skyscraper which is in theaters now
the rock is insisting on a separate
seven-figure social media fee with every
movie we were there's the rock screen
skyscrapers world premiere the 46 year
old actor has a staggering 110 million
followers on Instagram
[Music]